Within the surprising world,
the uncertainties are becoming higher and
higher due to potential risks,
changes in trade as well as
the changing technologies.
And the uncertainties
provide opportunities.
This program is not about just
how to do procurement, logistics.
But we try to link how product
development, design thinking,
customer service, channel managements,
are all integrated.
Because this is the new way.
Innovation is the centerpiece
of our focus.
You need to innovate the way you work.
Where you locate your factories?
How do you do outsourcing, offshoring?
Reassuring.
Self driving cars, robots, 3D printing,
you can recreate a new
form of a supply chain.
>> This program gives you
a complete supply chain view.
All the way from defining
the strategy to your execution.
So it gives you the full visibility on
how you can improve your supply chain.
>> Supply chain today has evolved
into becoming a weapon for attack.
It is a value creating strategy to
gain market share in new markets.
Increase revenues to improve margins.
>> We were given the tools to meet
the challenges that we are facing today.
>> The business cases
are absolutely fantastic.
>> You need to strengthen your partners,
you need to strengthen your supply bases,
you need to strengthen your
customer relationships so
that it's holistic involving
every member of the supply chain.
>> I can only remain in business
if I bring value to my customers,
because it's all about value.
>> If I go to my customers, I'm able to
show them what I am doing differently.
>> A good football team must have
good defense, and also good offense,
and we are helping our executives
to build a foundation of defense,
but also have really
strong offense as well.
>> I'm very,
very impressed by the passion of the
people that are teaching these classes.
>> I would recommend this schools to
anybody who wants to make their supply
chain more strategic.
>> We want our target
executives to think big.
Willing to leverage innovations.
>> This is a course that I'll
definitely recommend to others.
>> I believe that to be the best,
you have to learn from the best.
>> I truly believe that this is the best
supply chain programs in the world.
[MUSIC]